welcome to my talk about
efficient method validation workflow
with full device integration
today we will focus on efficient method
validation workflow with full device
integration
this presentation will provide guidance
and show optimized workflows and tools
for selecting and implementing the ideal
method validation solution
that will save up to 70 percent compared
to perform with
tasks manually as you can see in the
chart
using an effective solution will reduce
up to 70 percent of your time at cost
overview what is important for an
efficient workflow
guidelines for method validation
analytical method
validation work is based on a variety of
guidelines and requirements
ich usp epjp dean ios or fda
and visa and lots of other guidelines
are important
these guidelines define the basics of
validation work
the purpose the scope and what to do
our goal method validation work requires
more effort than ever
beginning with analytical and scientific
work and even more reports and
compliance documentation
lots of paperwork reducing this work
and improving efficiency while ensuring
the highest level of documentation
quality
and data integrity is welcomed by both
qa
and laboratory how can this be achieved
analytical method validation what do we
need for our work
the objective of the validation of an
analytical procedure is to demonstrate
that it is suitable for its intended
purpose
efficiency and data integrity are the
most important requirements for method
validation software solutions
what does that mean and how can it be
achieved
both in terms of time from planning to
final report
and in terms of good and compliant
output
first efficiency in terms of time from
planning to find a report
the workflow should be well-defined
this is your sop task easy to understand
and easy to follow
guided by wizards assistance to do this
eliminating the need to use additional
tools
like pocket calculator excel or slide
ruler
second efficiency in terms of good and
compliant output
a validated calculation framework is
mandatory
but we need more we need predefined
result sets
that is well-defined output with no
random changes
layouts corporate identity including
logos
headers cover pages summaries
easily summarizing a validation
project's main results
formulas optional report elements for
better documentation
but validation project should not only
contain calculations but all data
integrity related info
21 severe part 11 compliance
data integrity full compliance to 21
serial part 11 or equivalent regulations
like eu
gmp annex 11. data protection can be
guaranteed by software access levels
logins roles departments and check some
protected backend databases
like sql servers the whole workflow must
be completely checked by means of audit
trails
all activities in detail as well as
revision history
searchable and retrievable auditors have
a very close look on all aspects of
electronic data
21 cfl part 11. besides validation and
part 11 compliance certificates
a 21 cfr part 11 compliance response is
mandatory
this compliance response provides
detailed answers for the requirements of
part 11
it's a mandatory document when using a
software in regulated environments
it is part of your software
documentation as well as iq and ocu
protocols
and other quality related paperwork
workflow establishing an optimized
workflow with minimum effort
templates the key for optimized workflow
is predefining all aspects of typical
method validation work
by workflow templates that reduce new
projects to a few clicks
such templates follow your sops contain
typical workflows and workloads
and structure your tasks to optimize
efficiency and compliance
communication with your laboratory
equipment like cds
lins ecm erp dms
should be automatic and easy with manual
intervention limited
to a minimum
guidelines and validation structure
guidelines are translated into
validation workload for example
checkpoints to create and structure
validation projects
as you can see this example
software product has translated all
these guidelines
into checkpoints and these checkpoints
are available
for creating and structuring new
validation projects
testing workload your testing workload
is defined by your
accreditation authority customers sops
and your personal ambitions
in any case the testing workload must be
well defined and not random
it must be clear why a specific workflow
as well its acceptance tracking has been
selected
this workflow definition is established
as a validation plan
that needs to be approved prior to data
acquisition start
custom workflows
adopting new or changed workflows should
be as easy as possible
graphical design tools business process
managers
allow user-designed workflows without
software modification
different projects require different
workflows that can be selected from
predefined designs
documentation more than result
calculation
documentation method validation work is
much more than just calculating results
it is setting up your testing workload
both simple and flexible
with final documentation magic customer
expectations
as well as regulatory requirements
this requires a highly configurable and
powerful reporting solution
to create documentation templates for
all purposes
internal as well as official validation
reports
best practices
important and frequently used report
elements should be available for
immediate usage
for example text blocks snippet
libraries
ease this process and guarantee good
reporting quality
this applies to headers approval
sections cover pages
resulted acceptance tables and lots of
other elements
final documentation final method
validation documentation needs to be
easy to understand well structured
illustrated when necessary easily
summarized to get the main result
document transfer and protection
final documents must follow established
standards for easy exchange
like pdf a 1b
2b 3b and they must be well protected by
secure algorithms
like aap
document transfer and protection
final documents must follow established
standards for easy exchange
like the pdfa standard and well
protected by secure algorithms
that give a good protection against
hacking
integration full device integration is
the key
manual data input should be avoided
whenever possible
automatic transfer eliminates the need
to control and check manual inputs
all laboratory systems need to be
attached to your method validation
software
like cds chromatography data systems
limbs lab information management systems
erp enterprise resource planning ecm
enterprise content management and dms
document management systems
interface workflow interfaces connect
your validation projects to external
data sources
data is automatically transferred
predefined workflows control data flow
and reduce time and eliminate input
errors
a new validation project is created
based on an improved template
it connects to a data source like cds
lims erp or ecm
it assigns and load data by using an
automatic data transfer
and it creates a final validation report
using the pdf a
format that is protected and sent
[Music]
flexibility even a method validation
project based on a well-established
template might need modifications for a
specific pending project
product fine tuning while templates
define routine work
it's critical to allow flexibility for
each new project
additional calculations graphics and
report extensions must be added easily
as it is viable to allow fine tuning of
your projects for a specific purpose
for example different testing workflow
additional calculations
or modified layout in any case
such modifications must be fully tracked
the difference to the underlying
template explained
and justified in the validation plan
data integrity your data is worth being
protected
you need a maximum level of data
integrity since your data is worth being
protected all this must be accompanied
by a maximum level of data integrity
which means strict access control
detailed traceability version history
and full twenty-one severe particle
compliance
centralized installations application
database server
are strongly recommended to keep your
data safe and to ease application
rollouts
and maintenance installation
qualification must be ensured by
automated
iq and oq processes as well as
pq workflows
tools for qa and it admins and qa have
lots of requests for data integrity
and consistency checks to be carried out
on a regular basis
all these queries can be done based on
existing auditory information
and should be available on a single
click with graphical output dashboards
and report output before documentation
summary efficient method validation
workflow with full device integration
our goal should be to work as efficient
as possible with the highest level of
documentation quality
data integrity is a core requirement
tool get it into your lab workflow with
interfaces
to all relevant systems cds lims erp
ecm dms approved templates for routine
work are mandatory
but flexibility and fine tuning of
projects are necessary
tools must be validated and the
installation qualified
iq oqpq
in case you want to contact me for to
get further information
on optimized workflows please feel free
to contact me at any time
you can see my phone numbers my email
address
and our company home page thank you